welcome back to Facebook uncensored from
Queen consort to Simply Queen Camila
will go by a new title following the
coronation tomorrow represents a long
journey in the public side from the
Royal Outsider often Savaged by the
media and the public to woman prays for
her wisdom and get on with its Spirit
she also of course spawned over the lake
Queen Elizabeth who backed it to be
Queen consort at the start of her
Jubilee year Her Majesty wrote a public
letter which she said in the fullness of
time my son Charles becomes king I know
we'll give him and his wife Camilla the
same support you've given me and it's my
sincere wish that when that time comes
Camilla will be known as Queen consort
if she continues her own loyal service
so after a pretty Rocky history with the
public is the nation ready to hail Queen
Camilla well joining me now is the
former private secretary to Princess
Diana Patrick Jefferson the thought
Tiffany contributors Esther cracker and
Ava Santina welcome to all of you
Patrick
could you have ever imagined when we
used to occasionally chat in the Diana
days
particularly actually after the tragedy
of Diana's death in 1997 that here we
would be
20 odd years later
about to have Camilla crowned queen of
this country
in the immortal words of Meghan Markle
love wins right
no I mean it is it is an extraordinary
Journey as you've described it yeah yes
I mean uh the
the opportunity to even imagine
something like that just didn't come my
way
it isn't it is I think for Palace
strategist the job isn't done depending
which pole you look at either 86 or even
90 of people don't approve of the
terminology the term Queen right now
I'll give her a lot of ground I've
actually had people say to me I thought
the Queen Elizabeth said she was going
to be Queen consort what happened to
that and when did when did it become
Queen and they do have a bit of a
problem with that I don't but they do
well because they remember the queen and
you know people talk about the queen and
people remember the queen trying to
readjust recalibrate to Queen Camilla it
does seem strange and you can ask did
the late Queen have an idea in her mind
when she said Queen consort she meant
what she said yeah she did it was in
writing Esther it's a bit of a hot
potato they've had a few this week the
oath of Allegiance went down like a lead
balloon most people just want nothing to
do with that but this issue of whether
she should be Queen of the queen or
Charles's Queen console it's a big
difference actually I think because the
queen was so highly respected I think
they should have stuck to exactly what
she said and just made her Queen concert
I think you are pushing it with just
saying Camilla is the queen especially
because there's a generation of people
that really remember the whole Camilla
Diana Charles Saga that are not over it
there's always going to be that wound
there's Camilla was The Other Woman and
as much as she's atoned and people
understand that people grow and change I
think you're pushing it with Queen
Camilla Ava do you care do you know this
is the one part of that I do care about
because I mean it's going to shock you
I'm not a monarchist but the one thing I
like is the Pomp and the ceremony and
the ritual and so for me Camilla can't
be Queen Diana is Queen she will be and
she's she won't be queen and the queen
either
but you know I would have loved more I
would have love to see what Diana would
have worn I would have loved it oh yeah
well actually I would read at all I
would have loved I knew Donna quite well
I would love to have seen Donna's face
at the moment that Crown goes on
Camilla's head I mean Patrick I don't
think it's probably breaking any
discreet secrets to say she wouldn't
have been happy well you know Pierce
Diana always surprised you
um that is true and you know Andrew
Parker Bowles is going to be in the
congregation I know
um and Diana
she was she was an extraordinarily
mature and wise woman in many ways and
she recognized that her husband needed
this person for whatever reason she
couldn't fathom it necessarily but she
said you know he needs this woman and
Diana was reconciled to that largely and
I think that for her Uppermost
she had a great love for her husband and
the thought that if if this other woman
could make him happy I think she would
have made her peace with that she would
have had her own life to get on with and
it would have been fantastic that's true
and I think um I mean I I've got to know
Camilla quite well over the years we've
actually come from neighboring villages
in East Sussex literally a mile apart so
we always had that little connection and
uh I really like her she's a very
down-to-earth warm no-nonsense kind of
person all her family are just as the
same
um and she's been indisputably as to
whatever we think of the the love issues
there the triangle and so on the three
of us are Miss marriage she has been a
constant Rock for Charles and I think if
it hadn't been for her I would have
really really concerned about him oh
absolutely I think she's really sort of
centered him in many ways but also she's
also a very strong woman I've often made
the point that I couldn't have gone
through what she went through and still
have chosen to I mean when Meghan Markle
bleeds about media attention exactly I
mean she's not even a first base Camilla
had 30 years of this and it was vicious
I mean far worse
I know you've got no idea this is the
trouble you youngsters you have no idea
I still get messages from my mother it's
like how can Camilla and I'm like do you
know I don't think the internet will
ever recover from Diana what could have
been what what could it be but I do
forget people often forget Diana had her
own life and she also had her own Affair
you know what here's the truth about
everyone involved in this Andrew Parker
Bowles Camilla Charles Diana let me tell
you the common denominator they all had
a fortnight yeah they all had affairs
all of them yeah right so the idea
there's some angel in the middle of this
or some you know guy who's been badly
treated it doesn't stack up to the
actual facts they all had affairs and it
was messy but out of it all Camilla's
retained a great love and good
relationship with her ex-husband Andrew
he'll be there at the coronation and I
think Dinah would have come to terms
with this actually I think she knew she
knew that Charles is great love probably
in the end was Camilla but Pierce don't
you think that the issue here is not
Camilla it's what happened because of
Camilla it's that total reset of
relations between the palace and the
media and not in a good way it's totally
corroded that relationship because in
order to reinvent Camilla Charles's
office had to import political style
spin to Royal media relations and
they've never recovered that may be true
but there may have been no other way I
want to take a little clip this is Tom
Parker Bowles Camilla's son a great guy
this is what he said
but does it feel weird for you to start
sort of having thinking of hours as the
queen not really because she's still you
know my mother I say ah speaking not not
the Royal East but between my sister and
me
um but she is oh yeah she's our mother
and it's I think change happens but I
don't care what anyone says this wasn't
any sort of end game she married the
person she loved and this is what
happened
he's great Tom but I mean I sat next to
Camilla When Donald Trump was in town
and she'd just been with him for the day
with Charles and I sat next to dinner
that night and I won't reveal what she
said about it but she was hilarious
about it and I just felt that she could
do anything Camilla she's she's a
perfect console for one of a better
phrase for Charles she's always there
just gets on cracks on whether it's
Donald Trump with all that chaos coming
into town or whether it's a small
dutiful Act of some small charity that
they're going to she just seems nothing
phases her and that's a powerful tool
for someone in her position no
absolutely I think one of the the things
that has been missing is the word Duty
right I think Camilla is gives gives
people that she the sense that she has a
sense of Duty which some members or
former members of the royal family I
can't say have always had that and I
think that's pretty refreshing and she
said to me you know uh she said there's
an easy way to do this she said you just
it's never complain yeah never explain
yeah and rarely be heard speaking in
public I mean I think that was a queen
mother template actually which the queen
certainly had Camilla has she's never
engaged over in any of the and I promise
you it was 10 times whatever you think
Meghan markle's had Camilla was Savaged
by the media by the public by everybody
everyone like you loved Diana I love
Donna she was a fantastic person had
great lunches with her I would speech on
the phone about stuff with you know all
sorts of stuff used to go on behind the
scenes when Harry wants to know where
most of the best juicy stories came from
trust me often his mother right so she
could manipulate the media as Patrick
knows better than anybody
um I didn't blame her because she was on
the receiving end of it but I think that
uh with this one I think when you start
getting into the blame game you're
missing the bigger point which is
actually they all had their problems and
in the end the Charles Camilla love
story is a big real one yeah possibly
can I introduce you to an internet term
that's going around on a tech talk most
under 40s are using it's uh what is it
side chick
[Music]
[Laughter]
have I